I had a buddy from high school and he
was like hey this is what I'm doing with
my contracting business I was like okay
sweet so you're just going to see all
your roofing business he's like yeah but
I also do some like lips in real estate
I was like okay so you do roofs and you
do real estate flipping I mean we also
do some general contracting work just
kind of like fix stuff inside of houses
it's like okay why I do it because I
don't want to leave money on the table
the question is what problem are we
solving if the goal is to grow the
business do we think that we could have
a hundred million dollar roofing
business the answer is yes do we think
we could have a 100 million dollar
general contracting business the answer
is yes do you think we have a 100
million dollar flipping houses business
it's just yes can you have all three
very unlikely unless you're in Elon but
most people aren't and that's okay the
biggest mistake that I see is that they
are trying to solve their business
growth Problem by just trying to glob as
many different things as they possibly
can rather than thinking maybe I should
expand my audience and keep selling the
thing that I'm really good at you might
want to say okay which one of these am I
best at and which one of these do I
think I could serve the most people with